und du hast ja auch gesprochen mit der
oppositionspolitikerin maria callas die
cover da wollen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz
reinhören zusammen
proteste in kairo sind sehr
zentralisiert diese nicht koordiniert
oder organisiert von jemand denn er
sieht nicht so aus
und früher zum beispiel seit lässt der
26 jahren wir haben die man beobachtet
es gibt einen tag wo alle gehen auf die
straße oder im platz und die
protestieren und dann natürlich mit viel
gewalt es ist alles protest ist ruiniert
und nächsten fünf jahre drohte einfach
haben noch mehr angst und noch mehr
unfreiheit und so hat es immer
funktioniert jetzt ist ihm ganz andere
situation die proteste und die sehr
solide solidarität miteinander in
balance ist überall stattfinden so in
kleineren städten großer städte in
villingen ist es überall es ist auch als
sie sind nicht nur im zentrum von minsk
gesunden auch auf verschiedenen gebieten
und es hat noch nie so es war noch nie
so verbreitet und es war noch nie so
selbst organisiert paul hatte dir denn
noch mehr oft kamera erzählt die
oppositionsführung die
oppositionsführerin ist insgesamt
relativ optimistisch den gelacht bei
diesem interview ich habe sie auch
gefragt ob sie eigentlich angst hat auf
die straße zu gehen weil sie ja eine der
letzten drei verbliebenen prominenten
frauen ist wir wissen dass die
oppositionsführerin in litauen ist
momentan auch keine interviews gibt und
sie es weiter in ihrem nein ich habe
keine angst ich gehe in cafés ich
spreche mit den menschen ich bin weiter
draußen dort wo der protest passiert
erstaunlich war als wir mit ihr
gesprochen haben dass sie sagt sie sich
gegen sanktionen auch gegen sanktionen
gegen lukaschenko was sie sagt man
brauche dialog ich habe sie dann gefragt
ob sie glaubt dass küchen hier
eingreifen wird dass lukaschenko mehr
noch um hilfe bäten jetzt sie hat gesagt
ja davon geht er aus weil lukaschenko
als diktator hier im land bleiben will
oder nicht bereit sei ihr abzutreten und
sie sagt aber gleichzeitig sie glaube
nicht dass putin so dunkel sei hier
einzugreifen denn sie sagt sie auf
dieser position sei nicht gegen russland
oder gegen putin sie wollen
lukaschenko loswerden und sie hoffen
darauf indirekt auch auf putins
unterstützung und man hört sie wieder im
hintergrund sie rufe den airbus die
proteste reißt nicht ab und morgen wird
hier ein ganz großer tag erwartet viele
haben gehofft dass das der tag der
entscheidung werden könnte aber ich bin
da mittlerweile etwas skeptisch denn
lukaschenko versucht sich hier am amt zu
klammern
das sagt unser bild vize paul ronzheimer
vielen dank an dich pass auf dich auf
und ein schöner